[Musique]
pardon c'est bon bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans j'ai pas regardé à
diffuser bonjour à tous et bienvenue
dans je suis les eaux je suis pierre
toujours
notre temps de dire ça mais c'est vrai
on plonge désinvité dans des situations
cocasses et à l'aide d'un habile système
d'oreillettes on les guide dans des
défis un peu rigolo et aujourd'hui oui
du mois vont accueillir quand t'es loin
t'es bien que fait un petit bisou à mort
et du coup parce qu'il n'est pas là mais
on sait pas nécessaire aujourd'hui on
est dans une salle de sport et donc tu
vas donc piégé les abonnés de cette
salle de sport j'ai l'impression que tu
as une grande notoriété en ce moment
ouais j'ai peur que les gens
reconnaissent c'est possible juste
ophélie faire un petit make up vous qui
voit là on reconnaisse pas trop tu vois
nickel je me dis si c'est bon est ce que
tu es prêt quand un peu la pause et
rapide dans un contre le mur quand
l'élan un petit peu les tirs 2 ans tu
peux demander un mec de faire le goal
si vous n'avez pas de vous mettre là et
j'essaie 2 vous mettez la démonter comme
ça
j'essaie de haut qu'il arrête qu'ils
arrêtent les grands encore un petit tu
peux aller prendre si tu veux la halle
espèce de petit socle et la grêle est
petite et petite boulette
tu peux être sûr que tu fais des petits
les petits secrets pauline et qui
demande au moci à ta droite si c'est
comme ça qu'il faut faire quand on sait
comment ça va leur position soit comme
sa position soit formé par les mains
pour le problème mais j'ai l'impression
que c'est un gars pour info que je peux
tomber et ils tombaient dessus mais eux
un peu langoureusement que
jamais cela
[Musique]
c'est un fait ça lance à présent je suis
tout seul vous vous êtes tout seul sinon
vous êtes vous êtes tout seul aussi le
mec rien arrêté lui parler il fait des
roulades dans toute la salle
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'ai mis un peu plus haut le bar et tu
fais de limbo ok c'est ça eh bien tu
veux essayer c'est sûr qu'il ait envie
d'essayer si sur ces bilans moi je
penses tu pas se permettre
[Musique]
ok alors va te faire limbo de faire
l'exercice minimes et une foulure et tu
fais du clocher dans toute la salle
voilà à [__] fait le tour de la cage
feuilleton de la cage personne n'a
l'idée c'est fou elle vit encore et
c'est bien un peu plus ils s'en branlent
lisandro les gens saluent la vanne aux
mecs qu'elle situe lui fait enlever ces
écouteurs et du titre ivan café tu vas
me quitter ses comptes avant que c'est
une théière
du coup je propose du café sinon je peux
demander à quelqu'un de très honnête en
excuser moi ça vous dérange a juste de
me tenir les gens super moi je vais dans
la salle un peu pour reconquérir
maintenant j'ai mon ex steve jobs et la
fatigue je voulais ramener trop bien
tourné c'est trop facile mais elle est
toujours avec moi ok c'est bon allez
c'est parti on va se chauffer
est ce que vous êtes chaud j'entends
rien est ce que vous êtes chaud
j'entends rien j'entends vraiment rien
la vie en plus je sais pas comment
claudia mais enfin ça me dérange que tu
utilises celle ci après j'étais déçu
mais c'est toi place on peut en faire
ensemble
est ce que tu veux pas essayer de faire
un méga jenga et c'est d'empiler tous
les demis ballon qu'il ya derrière toi
si quelqu'un peut m'aider à les empiler
ça serait cool de me collard mesdames si
vous voulez de l'année la barre 3 s et
gagner là bas demandé si quelqu'un peut
prendre en photo devant en oeuvre s'il
te plaît mais je voulais essayer de
sauter au dessus des défis en combinant
ses tapas dit le totem effet le fils
sans avoir prépare toi mentalement et
physiquement mais toi accroupi devant
exclu le signe de 12 et tu te fais mal
on espère que vous avez aimé ce premier
épisode de gaz dans l'oreillette on se
retrouve bientôt avec aurillac qui devra
piéger les clients d'une boutique de
cosmétiques d'ici là retrouvez nous sur
nos chaînes youtube respectives toutes
les infos sont dans la distribution et
moi je vous fais des bisous des bisous
bah quoi c'est tout moi ont tué leur
dire quoi